لاكثر من عشرين عاما كان النجم كريستيانو
رونالدو على راس لاعبه العالم هدافا محققا
للبطولات الشخصيه والجمعيه مع الفرق التي
مثلها فضلا عن بطولاته مع منتخبه البرتغال
البرتغالي يعد احد ابرز نجوم الساحره
المستديره فهو صاحب الخمس كرات ذهبيه
واكثر نوح الجائزه فرديه خلال مسيره
الاسطوره المستمره الوحيد والاوحد الفيلم
الوثائقي الجديد عن حياه وقصه ابداع
رونالدو خلال مسيرته الذي تقدمه قناه
العربيه لتروي قصه حب وتعلق بين رونالدو
وكره القدم انتجت نجما عالميا قل نظيره
اليوم سنتعرف اكثر على تجربه رونالدو
انتقاله للرياض لتمثيل احد الفرق الكبيره
في السعوديه نادي النصر السعودي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الفائز بخمس جوائز كره ذهبيه ومحطما الرقم
القياسي استحق الجائزه هذا العام كنت
استحق اكثر العام الفائت انا سعيد بمجموعه
29 جائزه وطنيه ودوليه انه فوزي الاول في
دوري الابطال شعوري مذهل كما تعلمون انها
لحظه رائعه واكثر من 700 هدف خلال مسيرته
الكرويه وهذا جزء مما حققه خلال مسيرته
الكرويه الاحترافيه العالميه على مدى 17
عاما يعرف كل ارقام ريال مدريد القياسيه
ولا يزال يحرز الاهداف لاعبون مذهلون
ساعده ابداعه وسرعته ورؤيته الحالمه في ان
يصبح واحدا من اعظم اللاعبين في التاريخ
استعد دائما بالطريقه نفسها لا يهم الفريق
الذي سالعب ضده يبقى تركيزي بالمستوى نفسه
دائما
استعد دوما بالطريقه نفسها لا يهمني ضد اي
فريق سالعب يبقى تركيزي هو نفسه
ربما حين العب ضد اكبر الفرق تكون الحماسه
لدي اعلى قليلا لكن الامر سيان اركز
ذهنيا دوما على تقديم افضل ما لدي لم يكن
يتطور فقط من ناحيه مهاراته بل بدا موقفه
خلال المباريات يتغير ايضا
وللحديث عن الوحيد والاحد ينضم الينا وحيد
المصري الصحفي في قسم الرياضه معانا في
الاستوديو اهلا يا وحيد منورنا من جديد
الوثيقي الوحيد والاحد للعربيه عن
كريستيانو رونالدو اسرار ومعلومات لاول
مره حدثنا عن فكره الوثائقي طبعا
كريستيانو رونالدو هي قصه ملهمه
تحب كريستيانو كمشجع لكره القدم او لا
تحبه لا يمكنك الا ان تعجب بالاصرار
والمثابره واذا اذا الجمهور اللي تابع
الوثائق عبر شاشه العربيه التي تنفرد بهذا
الوثائق الوحيد والاوحد البدايه جدا مهمه
لانه رونالدو لم يولد وفي فمه ملعقه ذهبيه
كما يقال مولود في جزيره مديره ليس جزء من
البر الرئيسي للبرتغال ولكن في البحر في
المحيط المتوسط يعني مسافه بعيده حتى يصل
الى العاصمه لشبولا ويلفت انظار كشافين
نادي سبورتنج لشبونه كان لابد ان يمتلك
موهبه
جذابه كبيره في سن العاشره يغادر
جزيرته واهله ويرتحل يعيش في الاكاديميه
احنا طبعا عندما نتابع مسيره لاعب كره قدم
ننظر الى النتائج المبهره الارقام
والجوائز والاهداف البدايات جدا مهمه
طفل يعني عشر سنوات 12 سنه ما زال طفل
يذهب ليعيش في مدينه بعيده
وبدينه هي العاصمه الكبرى للبلاد مقارنه
في ان نسميها المدينه الصغيره او القريه
الصغيره التي كان يعيش فيها مقارنه سنوات
هذه هي اللي بنت شخصيته الاعتماد على نفسه
المثابره الاستماع والانضباط مع المدربين
وجميع الطاقم اللي موجود كان في سبورتين
وبعدها بدا يلفت انظار انديه الكبرى
والانتقال الى مانشستر يونايتد وتبدا
المسيره الكبيره الوحيد هل سيكشف الوثائقي
عن امور قد لا نعرفها او لم نقرا عنها عن
حياه كريستيانو رونالدو طبعا مشكله الشهره
انه جميع تفاصيل حياتك بتكون موجوده على
العلم
يبقى ما يكشف اللاعب نفسه ما يتحدث به
نفسه عن مشاعره عن لحظات مهمه مصيريه في
حياتهم يمكن كان سمعنا اراء من حوله عنها
لكن لم نسمع رونالدو نفسه يتكلم عن هذه
اللحظات عن هذه القرارات المصيريه التي مر
فيها في مسيرته وهنا ياتي التميز في
الوثائقي طيب رونالدو الدون موجود اليوم
في نادي النصر السعودي كيف كان تجربته مع
النادي طبعا ممكن ما زال مبكرا الحكم بشكل
كامل البدايات مبشره ليس فقط في النتائج
في ارض الملعب وتسجيل الثمانيه اهداف رغم
انه لم يسجل في المباراه الماضيه للنصر
لكن التاثير الاشمل من مجرد وضع الكره في
الشباك شاهدنا عده قنوات عالميه تلفزيونيه
طلبت وحصلت على حقوق نقل مباريات النصر
ربما فقط او الدوري السعودي ككل يعني
المنتج الذي بدا وهو ايضا يعني منتج جذاب
لجمهور معين اصبح الان يخاطب جمهور اكبر
ساحه عالميه اكبر اي حركه واي رمسه واي
تصريح واي لمحه يقدمها رونالدو نشاهده في
نفس اللحظه عبر وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
وكبريات الصحف العالميه
ومعها الدوري السعودي يعني هذه دعايه لا
تقدر بثمن يمكن اكبر من اي ثمن دفعه نادي
النصر
للحصول على رونالدو
بشكل شخصي يعني اذا ما دخلنا في الحياه
الشخصيه
اكثر من عالم الرياضه الى عالم السياحه
والاقتصاد يعني من هنا انطلق هذا المساله
نشاهد بان رونالدو اندمج بسرعه مع المجتمع
السعودي يرتدي الثوب السعودي هو وابنه
بروح البر حتى جورجينا يعني تصر انه تحط
اللوكيشن دائما المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بصورها على انستجرام ماذا لا ذلك اليوم
طبعا هذا ذكاء كبير من رونالدو هو ليس
مجرد طبعا بالنهايه اللاعب ياخذ راتب هو
موظف يؤدي مهمته وياخذ راتبه لكن رونالدو
ليس فقط مجرد موظف يؤدي المهمه هو اذكى من
ذلك وهو ما اثبت على مسيره الطويله يبحث
عن الاندماج وهو فعلا يعني ليس بالشخص
اللي مجرد يضع صور او فيديوهات او يشارك
في النشاطات لانه مجبر على ذلك كما يمكن
ان يقال في العقد المكتوب لكنه مندمج فعلا
يعني انا قابلته شخصيا في دبي شخص جدا
سعيد في المنطقه العربيه في الشرق الاوسط
والتعامل باريحيه اكثر اجدوا انه اتعامل
هنا وجد الريحيه اكثر مقارنه باوروبا اللي
ممكن التدقيق اكثر ونظر في تفاصيل بعيده
عن انجازاته الكرويه سعيد خلينا نقول اللي
سعاده جورجينا ايضا
كيف ترد على كل من يقول انه محمد صلاح
يمكن ان ينتهي رياضيا خصوصا انه اصبح
الهداف التاريخي لليفربول طبعا محمد صلاح
في كل مره يثبت بانه لم ينتهي محمد صلاح
خلنا ناخذ التصور العام مولود في بسيون في
مصر
والان هو هداف لفريق ليفربول الذي تاسس
عام 1892 بطل دوري ابطال اوروبا ست مرات
منها واحده مع محمد صلاح يعني الاستيعاب
ما يقدم محمد صلاح يجب ان نتذكر بان
الهداف التاريخي
قبل منه مايكل يعني اسماء كنا واحنا صغار
نحط البوستر تبعها ونشوفها على التلفزيون
والان واحد منا محمد صلاح ربما نشعر بقيمه
ما قدمه من انجازات تاريخيه بعد اعتزاله
لانه للاسف الان في الثلاثينات من عمره
يمكن خمس او ست سنوات ويعتزل نحتاج نحتاج
الى التوقف والنظر مليا بما قدمهم
الانجازات ليس فقط في تسجيل الاهداف وايضا
في صناعتها دائما الناس بتروح على الاهداف
مبارح سجل هدفين وصنع هدفين يعني يحتاج
ربما الى وقت اطول لتقييم ما قدمه صلاح
بشكل موضوعي ومنطقي من مجرد الرد الفعلي
لدينا الان ربما بسبب امور اخرى ليست
متعلقه باداء داخل الملعب لكن صلاح هو
تاريخ